welcome back okay we're talking about
nonlinear system identification for
control purely from data okay so we've
been using data-driven regressions to
obtain both linear and nonlinear system
models and we've talked about how you
can use model predictive control once
you have those system models to optimize
your control strategy for nonlinear
control okay so that's what we're gonna
talk about now is essentially how do I
combine model predictive control with
something like Cindy a sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
with control model okay so this is kind
of the overarching model predictive
control framework this is in the context
of a reference tracking problem and this
is you can read more about this in Orica
kaiser's archive paper on model
predictive control with with sparse
non-linear models
here's kind of the block diagram of what
model particular control is doing you
essentially have some reference value
you're trying to track you have some
predictor this is the model of your
system so this is where your Cindy with
control model is going to be and
essentially at every time step what you
do is you use this model to optimize
your control input over some short time
window and then you use that control
input that that first value of your
optimizing control signal you enact that
you see where your system goes and then
at the next time step you rerun an
optimization so for every time step
you're running an optimization into the
future based on your model and you're
picking the first actuation signal and
using it then you reinitialize your
optimizer pick the next first actuation
signal initialize it and you keep
walking forward in time
that's essentially what model predictive
control is doing so over here you can
see this in in a cartoon you have your
actual state trying to track some set
point this is your optimizing this is
what your your model thinks is the
optimum control input in the future and
you essentially lock in this optimizing
control value for the next time step
your system steps forward and then you
re initialize your optimization
move this window over and you redo
everything again you re optimized you
pick that next control value you step
your system forward you re optimized and
so on and so forth so model predictive
control is extremely flexible very very
powerful this is the industry standard
kind of advanced process control now
because it's so flexible and you can
include constraints you can do this for
nonlinear systems in the past because
this optimization was run at every time
step this was pretty expensive and so
often this was only feasible for linear
models okay so for linear or linear
parameter varying models but as
computers are getting faster and faster
essentially it's getting more and more
feasible for us to use nonlinear models
in this predictor step okay so what
Erika has done is essentially taken
these nonlinear model identification
techniques like Cindy sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics and
she's using those directly for online
control in a model predictive controller
so just to refresh your memory this is
the Cindy with control diagram so you
have data collected from some unknown
system so you measure the states in time
and the actuation signal you you build a
big nonlinear library of candidate
functions for the right-hand side of
these dynamics and you apply sparse
regression to find the fewest active
terms in the dynamics that agree with
your data so you get this sparse
nonlinear system that also includes the
effective actuation okay that's Cindy
with control and what Erik is doing is
now using these identified models these
purely data-driven sparse models with
model predictive control the cool thing
about this framework with using these
Cindy models for model predictive
control is that unlike other nonlinear
system identification because these are
sparse models they only have the the
fewest necessary terms required to
describe these measured dynamics these
are actually pretty fast to simulate I'm
not simulating really really complicated
deep neural nets or kind of black box
models these are very efficient to
simulate because they have the fewest
terms required to explain the
and they're also highly interpretive so
you can actually read off what terms are
active in the dynamics and interpret
what the nonlinearities are you can do
analysis you can find fixed points
anything like that's okay but these are
especially good for model predictive
control because they're very very fast
and they can also be identified using
very small amounts of data compared with
neural networks
okay so Erika has applied this to tons
of different systems she's applied it to
the predator prey model the chaotic
lorentz system she's also applied it to
flight control of a fighter and HIV
suppression in an HIV model so you can
use this data driven model discovery and
model predictive control framework in
all of these examples you can read about
it in her archive paper and I'm just
gonna walk you through how this works on
the lorentz system okay so essentially
what we're looking at here are the x y&z
time traces for the lorentz system
that's that chaotic lorentz system we
saw before for about I guess 10 time
units for various degrees of noise okay
so this Aida is the noise parameter and
it starts off small medium and large and
what we're plotting here is the
performance of a Sindhi with control
model and a neural network model for
these time windows and increasing noise
and what you can see here is for small
amounts of noise the Cyndi model
actually qualitatively tracks the true
dynamics for a very long time even
though this is a chaotic system it's
actually able to capture many of these
oscillations and Loubs switches of the
system until it starts to deviate around
here around you know time 37 whereas the
neural network model is deviating
significantly earlier even for a very
small noise now here you can see that as
I increase the noise the Cyndi model
starts to disagree with the the true
model more rapidly but the qualitative
dynamics the fact that the system has
lobe switching and spends certain amount
of time on one lobe and other amounts of
time on the other are actually
qualitatively captured quite well by the
sending
even for large noise so even with large
noise the Cindy model is qualitatively
capturing the right dynamics it's just
that because the system is chaotic this
noise is causing those two systems to
diverge earlier in time but you'll
notice that as I increase the the noise
the neural network model starts to get
worse and worse the qualitative aspect
of the neural network model is degrading
over time for increasing noise even
though the cindy model is capturing
these dynamics okay so we haven't done
any model predictive control yet this is
just comparing the actual model
performance of Cindy with control versus
neural networks for the Lorenz system
and you can see that because we're doing
this sparse regularized regression we
can essentially get away with cleaner
models that handle noise a little bit
better okay and because the actual
structure of the model is identified
instead of a black box the model
predictions in the future are
qualitatively more accurate now neural
networks I shouldn't disparage them too
much because the cindy model works
essentially because I had the right
dynamics in the library okay so the
actual true Lorentz dynamics were in the
library that I used for Cindy if my
library didn't include those dynamics it
would be terrible okay
and so the neural network model is in
general more powerful for unknown
dynamics really really complicated
dynamics I can fit a neural network
model whereas the cindy model really
requires that you have the right library
to represent those dynamics but if you
do it it performs very well and so
here's a kind of distillation of that
first figure where as we increase the
noise magnitude ada you can essentially
see what is the prediction horizon for
how long can I predict in the future
before my model deviates beyond an
acceptable tolerance and you can see
that consistently as noise increases
cindy has a larger prediction horizon
than neural networks which means that it
should be more useful for model
predictive control okay so the cindy
model agrees with the actual true
measurement data for a longer even an
increase
noise and so here's kind of the overview
figure of how Cindy works with model
predictive control on the actual lorentz
system okay so this is what we just saw
this increasing noise magnitude and
prediction horizon what we find is that
also the execution time so the Cindy
model executes much much more rapidly
than the neural network so the Cindy
controller runs in about 1.6 time units
whereas the neural network takes 35 so
the neural network is much more
expensive to simulate and less accurate
and the Cindy model is essentially
giving you these very fast and accurate
model predictions for for model
predictive control it also requires way
less training data and is much faster in
terms of training time okay so the cindy
model is faster and as a function of the
training data and it also as a function
of how much training data you have Cindy
identifies the correct model much much
more rapidly okay so what we're trying
to assess is if I only had limited data
to train these neural network and Cindy
models what would I what kind of model
would I get so as I increase the amount
of training data I have you can see that
the neural networks are very slow
expensive to train whereas scindia's
fast to train about two orders of
magnitude faster actually maybe four
orders of magnitude faster and in
addition as I increase the amount of
training data available very rapidly the
Cindy model has enough data to identify
the correct model and the prediction
horizon is good whereas it takes much
more data for the neural network to
identify an equivalent model okay so it
takes much much more data for the neural
network to get a good model than for
Cindy to get a good model and then
finally over here what we see is you
know we had these three different phases
so we train our data on this this type
of data then we change the control
signal and we see how good our
prediction is in this window and then
finally what we do is we enact our model
predictive controller in this last phase
to try to stabilize fixed a fixed point
of you know XY and Z and you
see that the Cindy model very very
rapidly is able to stabilize these even
for a nonlinear system using this model
predictive controller okay so Cindy is
able to accurately and aggressively
stabilize the system on these values
using the model that learned in this
training period okay just using model
predictive controller so Erika has
applied this to many many more systems
just like we talked about here you she's
applied this to predator prey fighter
jet HIV and Lorentz and so you can read
all about this and kind of figure out
how you could apply this to your system
but really what you need to know is if
you have measurement data of the state
of your system and the control input you
can build a Sindhi with control model
and then if you have some control
objective you can obtain that control
objective by using model predictive
control wrapped around that cindy model
okay thank you